رياح عاديه رؤيه شبه معدومه مباني طمرتها
المياه مروحيات تخترق الضباب اصوات تطلب
المساعده واخرى صمتت للابد هكذا بدل مشهد
في جزر البهاما مع بدايه موسم الاعاصير
بالمحيط الاطلسي عام 2019
فماذا حدث
في الرابع والعشرين من اغسطس عام 2019
تشكلت موجه الاستوائيه في وسط المحيط
الاطلسي وتعزز التدريجيا مع تحركها نحو
جزر الهند الغربيه قبل ان تتحول لاعاصره
هائجه
في الاول من سبتمبر وصل اعصار دوريان
ليابسه دوله جزر البهاما كاعصار من الفئه
الخامسه متسببا في فيضانات ودمار شامل في
جزيرتي اباكو وجراند بهاما شمال غرب
البلاد
استمرت العاصفه لمده 48 ساعه قبل ان تتوجه
لسواحل جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
حملت الرياح معها المياه والصخور وغمرت
الفيضانات المباني وانتزعت اسقف المنازل
وتطايرت شظايا السيارات
امتلات الطرق بالحطام والاشجار المتساقطه
فيما كانت امدادات الوقود محدوده كذلك كان
الوصول الى الجزر امرا صعبا للغايه حتى
بالنسبه الى فرق الانقاذ التي تدخلت لنقل
الاشخاص جوا من الجزيره الى ملاجئ في البر
الرئيسي
وفيما تسبب الاعصار في تدمير مبنى المطار
الرئيسي في جراند مهامه اصبح وضع الملاحه
صعبا وحصر الكثير من الاشخاص وسط المياه
ما تطلب الانقاذ بواسطه القوارب
حيث انقذ خفر السواحل اكثر من 200 و30
شخصا
انقطعت الخدمه عن المناطق المتضرره وفي
ولايه كارولين الشماليه وحدها فقد اكثر من
190.000 منزل الكهرباء خلال العاصفه كما
توقفت امدادات المياه النظيفه وتعطلت
سلاسل امداد التموين اما ما فاقم الكارثه
فتزامنها مع انتشار جائه كورولا لتعتبر
الحكومه المحليه جزر البهاما في وضعيه
ازمه انسانيه
استمرت اثار الاعصار خمسه ايام كانت كافيه
لتودى بحياه 74 شخصا مع بقاء 245 شخصا في
عداد المفقودين قالت الامم المتحده ان
70,000 شخص اصبح بلا ماوى وتضرر اكثر من
87% من جزر اباكو
فيما اشارت بيانات الاقمار الصناعيه الى
ان ما بين 76% الى 100% من مباني جزيره
جراند بهاما قد دمرت قد ضرب بنك تنميه
البلدان الامريكيه الاضرار المترتبه على
الاعصار بنحو ثلاثه مليارات و400 مليون
دولار وهو ما يعادل ربع الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لجزر البهاما بعد عام من الكارثه
بقي 29,000 و500 شخص بلا ماوى او عمل
وصنيف اعصار دوريان بين اقوى الاعاصير
التي ضربت المحيط الاطلسي والاقوى على جزر
قلبها
[موسيقى]